[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa conforme avanza la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 en el mundo
también se mueven las noticias falsas
sobre el tema en brasil e incluso el
mismo presidente ha promovido
información engañosa sobre la pandemia
aunque en las últimas semanas ha
aparecido distanciarse de algunas de sus
propias afirmaciones en este contexto
algunos de los más grandes medios de
comunicación del país se unieron para
combatir la desinformación y defender la
vacunación como la única salida frente
al joven 19 empezamos
la frase bastinas in o en español si a
la vacuna se lee y se escucha en redes
sociales la prensa y la televisión
brasileña se trata de una campaña con la
que algunos de los principales medios de
comunicación del país buscan hacerle
frente a la desinformación que se
propaga sobre la vacuna contra el kobe
19 a través de los periódicos folias de
sao paulo o estado de sao paulo y o
globo además de otros medios de
comunicación como las cadenas de
televisión globonews y tv globo el
proyecto pretende incentivar a la
población a vacunarse contra el kobe 19
pero también instan a quienes ya se
vacunaron a seguir cuidándose mientras
la inoculación avanza a ritmo lento a
mitades de abril cerca de 24 millones de
personas habían recibido la primera
dosis de la vacuna y para entonces el
ministerio de salud advirtió que de esa
cifra 1.5 millones de personas no
regresaron por la segunda dosis
la campaña vagina sin mi inicio en enero
pero la colaboración entre medios empezó
en junio del año pasado cuando el
ministerio de salud eliminó de su sitio
web los datos acumulados sobre los
afectados sin embargo dos días después
la justicia brasileña le ordenó a
revocar dicha medida desde entonces este
consorcio monitorea y difunde cifras
detalladas sobre el impacto del virus y
ahora también contabiliza la población
que ha empezado a recibir la vacuna que
ha sido lo más difícil desde entonces se
lo preguntamos a roberto de oliveira
editor de nuevos proyectos y alianzas
para el periódico folha de sao paulo
a la música
con cintra es conseguir concientizar e
informar a aquellas personas que por
ignorancia
por falta de información o por haber
sido manipuladas engañadas por haber
recibido una noticia falsa imaginan que
la vacuna no es nuestra única
alternativa
el imagina
que avecina no nos vamos a única
alternativa cada día nacen más campañas
y portales dedicados a frenar la
desinformación sobre el virus y las
vacunas pero no es raro que todavía haya
escepticismo entre un gran número de
brasileños pues su propio presidente
llegó a emitir mensajes engañosos sobre
varios temas generando confusiones
restando importancia a la gravedad de la
pandemia ya erbol sonar o llegó a
comparar el virus con una pequeña gripe
promovió la hidroxi cloroquina como
tratamiento pese a que su eficacia no
estaba comprobada mientras el resto del
mundo imponía estrictos confinamientos
para frenar el avance del cob y 19
bolsonaro promovía aglomeraciones y sin
mascarilla repartía abrazos a sus
seguidores en julio del año pasado dio
positivo por corona virus pero eso no lo
detuvo brasil es el segundo país más
afectado del mundo y atraviesa su peor
momento de la pandemia esto se debe en
parte al surgimiento de variantes más
contagiosas en su territorio y la
situación parece haber llevado a
bolsonaro a retractarse de algunas de
sus propias afirmaciones
el mandatario ha dejado claro que no se
vacunará en octubre se apresuró a decir
que no compraría la vacuna de la empresa
china sinovac que estaba siendo probada
en brasil en enero las autoridades
reguladoras aprobaron su uso y una
semana después el mismo bolsonaro
agradeció al gobierno chino por enviarle
insumos para producir la vacuna en
brásil
bolsonaro rechaza las medidas de
confinamiento porque dice que afectarán
la economía en repetidas ocasiones dijo
que todos vamos a morir algún día y que
no vale la pena huir del virus pero a
finales de marzo cuando el país veía
nuevos récords en el número de contagios
y muertes anunció la creación de un
comité de crisis para luchar contra el
cob y 19 productos
fue un encuentro muy provechoso armónico
de que primaba la solidaridad y la
intención de minimizar el impacto de la
pandemia poniendo las vidas de retos
tapas de vida
en primer lugar medios de comunicación
ajenos a esta campaña pero a favor de la
vacunación han advertido sobre los
peligros que representa no aplicarse el
antídoto el portal es de seis y titula
vacunas vacunas vacunas no hay
alternativa en brásil a gaceta dice que
el abandono de la vacuna es una amenaza
más para superar la crisis refiriéndose
a quienes no se aplicaron la segunda
dosis la edición en portugués del
periódico español el país titula de las
fer news a la desigualdad lo que lleva a
los brasileños a no tomar la segunda
dosis de la vacuna y agrega que estos
factores podrían comprometer la
protección colectiva según los expertos
la edición de salud de la revista bella
advierte que la bajísima cobertura sobre
todo en algunos públicos como mujeres
embarazadas y adolescentes muestra que
aunque no están desacreditadas las
vacunas están atravesando una crisis de
popularidad en el país añade que queda
por ver cuál será el impacto futuro de
las noticias falsas que
con la pandemia
y para el cierre facebook ahora busca
incursionar en el mercado de audio que
ha crecido notablemente en medio de la
pandemia el gigante de las redes
sociales anunció que sus usuarios podrán
escuchar podcast directamente desde su
plataforma y además integrar a
herramientas para la creación de audio
pero lo que más ha llamado la atención
es el anuncio de live audio rooms donde
los usuarios podrán crear foros de
discusión en vivo le suena este formato
pues los críticos han calificado esta
opción como un clon de clubhouse la
aplicación que nació hace un año y hoy
estaría valorada en 4 mil millones de
dólares cuatro veces más de lo que
facebook pagó por la adquisición de
instagram en 2012
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www france24
puntocom
[Música]